Here's what it's like to hold political office in the current economy. In the last year, Jay Nixon, the governor of Missouri, has done a steady stream of events announcing new jobs in this state, a new IBM office with 800 jobs, a Sabreliner expansion that'll create 400 new jobs. And in November, he went to a plant in Macon, Missouri, that makes fishing reels to announce not hundreds of jobs, or dozens of jobs, but eight jobs. Eight. He did a press event for eight jobs.
这就是在当前经济形势下担任公职的真实写照。在过去的一年里，密苏里州州长杰伊·尼克松一直马不停蹄地参加各种活动，宣布该州涌现出的新工作岗位：一个新的IBM办公室带来了800个岗位，Sabreliner公司的扩张将创造400个新岗位。而就在去年11月，他前往密苏里州梅肯市一家生产钓鱼卷线器的工厂，宣布的不是几百个岗位，也不是几十个岗位，而是八个。八个。他为这八个工作岗位专门举办了一场新闻发布会。
Well, I mean, that's not the smallest we've been to either. We actually did one in North Missouri where we created one job.
嗯，我的意思是，这还不是我们去过的最小规模的活动。我们实际上在北密苏里州做过一次，那里只创造了一个就业岗位。
And you showed up?
你还亲自去了？
Yeah. Right when I got started, I put together a small loan program. The businesses would complain that they didn't have access to capital. So we put a program together in which businesses could borrow up to $25,000 at 3% interest. And in Bethany, Missouri, a small town, a lady had a printing company printing t-shirts and signs in her basement. This allowed her to get a storefront and hire somebody to help her move forward.
是的。我刚开始工作时，就制定了一个小额贷款计划。企业总抱怨说它们无法获得资本。所以我们推出了一个项目，企业可以以3%的利率借款最多25,000美元。在密苏里州的贝瑟尼小镇，一位女士在地下室经营一家印刷公司，印制T恤和标语。这笔钱让她能够租下一个店面，并雇人帮助她进一步发展。
This is what it's come to, America. You can hire your very first employee and the governor shows up with TV cameras. You can't be politics in America right now without promising people jobs. Right? You know what I'm talking about? You've heard this from like every politician in America?
美国已经沦落到这种地步了。你雇佣了你的第一个员工，州长就要带着电视摄像机赶到现场。如今在美国，不承诺为人们创造就业就没法从政，对吧？你知道我在说什么吗？你从美国每个政客嘴里都听过这些话吧？
In a tough economy, we're working hard to create opportunity.
在经济困难时期，我们正努力创造机会。
It's still all about jobs.
一切还是围绕着就业。
When the President became President, we started creating jobs right away.
当总统就任总统时，我们立即开始创造就业机会。
We have a bipartisan bill that will create jobs immediately.
我们有一项两党法案，将立即创造就业岗位。
We're going to work hard, and our whole focus is get this state back to work.
我们将努力工作，我们的全部重心是让这个州重新投入工作。
A lot of people have been writing in, and calling in, and tweeting about jobs. They'd say, Mr. Trump, can we have a job? Can you help us get a job? Well, the fact is, if I run, and if I win, you'll have plenty of jobs.
很多人通过写信、打电话和发推特来谈论就业问题。他们会说，特朗普先生，我们能有一份工作吗？你能帮我们找份工作吗？事实是，如果我参选，如果我获胜，你们会有很多工作机会的。
That would be, of course, Newark Mayor Cory Booker, Alaska Senator Lisa Murkowski, Democrats Nancy Pelosi and Harry Reid, Florida Governor Rick Scott, and Donald Trump. In fact, if anyone these days brings up any subject besides jobs, people complain, why aren't we talking about jobs?
这些人当然包括纽瓦克市市长科里·布克、阿拉斯加州参议员丽莎·穆尔科斯基、民主党人南希·佩洛西和哈里·里德、佛罗里达州州长里克·斯科特，以及唐纳德·特朗普。事实上，如今如果有人提到除了就业以外的任何话题，人们就会抱怨，为什么我们不谈论就业呢？
Well, they got the photo. What to do about the photo?
嗯，他们得到了照片。关于那张照片该怎么办呢？
This is Rush Limbaugh last week, when they Obama administration was still deciding whether or not to release photos of the dead Osama bin Laden.
这是上周的拉什·林博，当时奥巴马政府还在决定是否公布本·拉登的遗体照片。
And the longer they dangle the photo release decision, well, then the more people that are distracted from the slow job growth.
他们拖延公布照片决定的时间越长，人们就越会被缓慢的就业增长所分散注意力。
Or, on the opposite side of the political divide, on the Rachel Maddow Show, Dean Baker of the Center for Economic and Policy Research asks here why are we focusing so much on the deficit?
或者，在政治分歧的另一端，在蕾切尔·玛多秀上，经济与政策研究中心的迪恩·贝克问道，为什么我们如此关注赤字？
To my mind it really is unconscionable just to sit back and have people go, oh, we're worried about the deficit, 10, 15, 20 years out, when we have 25 million people unemployed, underemployed, or out of the labor force altogether. So getting jobs in the economy really should be front and center.
在我看来，如果当我们要有2500万人失业、就业不足或完全脱离劳动力市场时，还要坐视不管，去谈论什么十年、十五年、二十年后的赤字担忧，这简直是丧尽天良。所以，让经济中的就业问题处于核心位置确实应该是重中之重。
Or, just to show the all-purpose usefulness of this trope, here's Republican Congressman David Rivera being questioned about an investigation into his campaign finances. The interviewer tells him,
或者，仅仅为了展示这个陈词滥调的多功能性，这里有共和党众议员大卫·里维拉，他正因竞选资金调查受到质询。采访者告诉他：
Some of this material did not come out during the campaign, so the voters didn't have a chance to size it up. And now that they see what was going on, frankly some of them feel had.
其中一些材料在竞选期间没有公布，所以选民没有机会进行评估。现在他们看到了发生了什么，坦率地说，有些人感到被欺骗了。
Well, actually, most of the people were concerned about the economy and job creation. They want me to go to Washington and do something about unemployment, job creation. That's exactly what I've been doing.
嗯，实际上，大多数人都关心经济和创造就业机会。他们希望我去华盛顿，在失业和创造就业方面做点实事。这正是他一直在做的事情。
See how easy?
看，多容易？
Well today on our radio show, with all these people saying it is time to create jobs, and promising that they're going to create jobs, and asking why aren't we spending more time talking about creating jobs, we ask, what does it even mean for a politician to create a job? Can they really create many jobs? Is that real? Is that a real thing? Is it possible the whole thing is just a lot of well-meaning hot air? From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. We've been looking into this for months with our colleagues from Planet Money. And we have answers. Stay with us.
今天在我们的广播节目中，面对所有这些人都在说现在是创造就业的时候了，承诺他们会创造就业，并质问为什么我们不花更多时间谈论创造就业，我们要问：政客创造一个工作岗位究竟意味着什么？他们真的能创造很多工作吗？那是真的吗？那是一件真实的事情吗？有没有可能这一切只是一堆出发点良好的空谈？这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目，由公共广播国际公司发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们和《金钱星球》的同事们一起调查了几个月。我们有答案。请继续收听。
Act One, Can the Government Move My Cheese?
第一幕，政府能移动我的奶酪吗？
All right. One of the big ways that politicians used to create jobs, the way that FDR did it back in the '30s-- put more people on the government payroll, build dams, build roads, spend and spend and spend-- nobody, nobody with any power anyway, seems to be talking about doing that. But there are all sorts of things that politicians are doing to create jobs, only they're jobs in the private sector. Chana Joffe-Walt explains how.
好的。政客们过去创造就业的一大方式，也就是富兰克林·罗斯福在30年代采取的方式——增加政府雇员，修筑水坝，修筑道路，不断支出、支出、再支出——现在似乎没人，至少没有掌握实权的人，在谈论这样做。但政客们正在用各种各样的方法来创造就业，只是这些都是私营部门的工作。查娜·乔菲-沃尔特解释了如何做到这一点。
In this story, I'm going to be talking about Wisconsin Governor Scott Walker. But I should tell you up front, I'm not going to be talking about any of the things you know or have heard about him, which I'm assuming are mostly this.
在这个故事里，我要谈谈威斯康星州州长斯科特·沃克。但我得先说明，我不会谈论任何你所知道或听到过关于他的事情，我想大部分应该是这些。
Governor Walker is proposing deep cuts in public employee pension and health care benefits, and is called for eliminated collective bargaining rights for everything but pay.
沃克州长提议大幅削减公共雇员的养老金和医疗福利，并呼吁取消除工资外的一切集体谈判权利。
We will not be denied our rights to collectively bargain.
我们绝不会被剥夺集体谈判的权利。
It is Walker's proposed budget cuts that have the unions now up in arms.
正是沃克的预算削减提议让工会现在群情激愤。
Yeah. Yeah, all that, I am not going there. I will not be saying the words union or collective bargaining in this story-- except for that time, and that's it. I want to talk about something else.
是的。是的，所有那些，我不会去谈论。在这个故事中，我不会说“工会”或“集体谈判”这两个词——除了刚才那次，仅此而已。我想谈谈别的事情。
So before Walker became famous nationwide for taking on Wisconsin's public unions, in Wisconsin, he was famous for this-- his pledge to create jobs, something Walker has never been understated about. Here he is at a campaign event in February of last year.
所以在沃克因对抗威斯康星州公共工会而闻名全国之前，他在威斯康星州就因这一点而闻名——他承诺创造就业机会，这是沃克从未低调过的事情。这是去年二月他在竞选活动中的讲话。
Today I want to make a first of its kind campaign announcement that I think is going to be earth-shattering. Today I announce in front all of you here today and everybody else who is going to be listening on the news and reading in tomorrow's newspaper that if you elect me as your next governor, I pledge to you here today, and to all the other citizens of the state of Wisconsin, that by the end of my first term we will create 250,000 new jobs in this state, and 10,000 new businesses by the end of that first term.
今天我要发布一个前所未有的竞选声明，我认为这将会是石破天惊的。今天我当着在座各位以及所有通过新闻收听和阅读明日报纸的人宣布，如果你选我作为下一任州长，我在此向你们及威斯康星州所有其他公民保证，在我的第一个任期结束时，我们将在本州创造25万个新就业岗位，并创造1万家新企业。
Walker's pledge to create jobs wasn't earth-shattering in and of itself. But what was interesting about it was that he was so specific. If we're going to look at how a politician creates jobs, this guy named a number, and not just once.
沃克的就业创造承诺本身并不惊人。但有趣的是他给出的数字非常具体。如果我们看看政客如何创造就业，这家伙给出了一个数字，而且不仅仅是一次。
No, in fact, he repeated it over and over and over again.
不，事实上，他反复地、反复地提到了这个数字。
This is Craig Gilbert, a political reporter for the Milwaukee Journal Sentinel.
这是《密尔沃基哨兵报》的政治记者克雷格·吉尔伯特。
250,000 jobs. I will create 250,000 jobs in my first term as governor. I mean, the message was the number.
25万个工作岗位。我会在担任州长的第一个任期内创造25万个岗位。我的意思是，信息的核心就是这个数字。
Last February into the spring, Scott Walker had two opponents, Democrat Tom Barrett and Republican Mark Neumann. For months, the two men ridiculed Walker's number, his specificity. They called his 250,000 jobs number meaningless, arbitrary, an empty promise. "Why 250,000?" they'd say? "Because it's a round number? Why not 285,000? 300,000?"
从去年二月到春天，斯科特·沃克有两位对手，民主党人汤姆·巴雷特和共和党人马克·纽曼。几个月来，这两人嘲笑沃克的数字和具体性。他们称他那25万个岗位的数字毫无意义、武断且是一个空头支票。“为什么是25万？”他们会说，“因为这是个整数吗？为什么不是28.5万？30万？”
This went on and on, until around June it quietly stopped. And the next thing that happened was that, one by one, Walker's opponents named their own numbers. First Barrett.
这种情况持续了很久，直到六月左右才悄悄停止。接下来发生的事情是，沃克的对手们一个接一个地给出了他们自己的数字。首先是巴雷特。
Our immediate goal is to regain the 180,000 jobs that we've lost during this economic downturn. That's what I propose today, a comprehensive vision to create Wisconsin jobs.
我们的近期目标是找回在这次经济低迷中失去的18万个工作岗位。这就是我今天提出的愿景，一个创造威斯康星就业的综合愿景。
Then Neumann.
然后是纽曼。
But when you put the package together, we're talking about 300,000 jobs in the state of Wisconsin by 2020. That's the target.
但当你把整个计划放在一起时，我们在谈论到2020年在威斯康星州创造30万个就业岗位。这就是目标。
They couldn't beat Walker at the numbers game. On November 2, Scott Walker, the first to name a number, won the election for governor. The 250,000 jobs man would have his opportunity to job create.
他们没法在数字游戏中击败沃克。11月2日，第一个给出数字的斯科特·沃克赢得了州长选举。这位“25万个岗位先生”将有机会去创造就业了。
So, is it working? Are jobs being created in Wisconsin? Sure, we're in a recovery from the worst recession since the Great Depression. You may have heard that. So yeah, there are new jobs in Wisconsin. All you have to do to see job creation happening is look in the newspaper, the Milwaukee Journal Sentinel classifieds. Bed Bath & Beyond has a couple positions, as do several fast-paced dentist offices. There are opportunities for self-starters interested in selling Hondas. Titan LED invites sales representatives to join the lighting revolution with a splashy full-pager.
那么，这奏效了吗？威斯康星州在创造就业吗？当然，我们正在从大萧条以来最严重的衰退中复苏。你可能听说过。所以是的，威斯康星州有了新的工作岗位。要看到就业创造的发生，你只需要看看报纸，《密尔沃基哨兵报》的分类广告。Bath & Beyond有几个职位，几个快节奏的牙医诊所也是如此。对于那些有兴趣卖本田车的人来说，有很多机会。Titan LED在一整页醒目的广告中邀请销售代表加入这场照明革命。
It's endless in terms of the opportunities. Because everywhere you look up, there's a fixture.
机会是无穷无尽的。因为你往上看，到处都是机会。
This is John Ruscigno performing his job title, Titan LED Marketing Director. He told me they're hiring sales agents like crazy right now. And these are newly created jobs. The company is brand new on the LED lighting scene, a booming industry.
这是约翰·鲁斯西诺，他的职位是Titan LED营销总监。他告诉我他们现在疯狂地在招聘销售代理。这些都是新创造的职位。该公司在LED照明领域是一个全新的品牌，这是一个蓬勃发展的行业。
Oh, it's phenomenal. There isn't a day that goes by that we don't have agents walking the door, and the phones are ringing, and we've got purchase orders coming in and shipments going out. So it's actively growing, and growing very aggressively.
噢，太惊人了。几乎没有一天没有代理人上门，电话铃响个不停，我们不断收到采购订单，货源也在不断发出。所以公司正在积极地扩张，而且是非常积极的扩张。
Two sections down in the want ads, Brookdale Senior Living is hiring 15 people. The ad explains, "Brookdale Senior Living is growing fast." And in person, the Executive Vice President and Treasurer Kristen Ferge explains why.
招聘广告往后翻两栏，布鲁克代尔养老院正在招聘15人。广告解释说：“布鲁克代尔养老院发展迅速。”而在现场，执行副总裁兼财务主管克里斯汀·弗格解释了原因。
There's just a huge disconnect between the supply and the demand in the later years.
老年人的供应和需求之间存在巨大的失衡。
Translation, there's about to be a lot of old people. There aren't enough places to put them. And that's what Brookdale offers, places for old people.
翻译一下，就是有很多老人即将出现，但没有足够的安置地方。而这正是布鲁克代尔提供的：老年人的安置点。
But-- and this is an important but-- I asked the LED guy if he had heard of Governor Walker's job creating plans. He had not. Nor had the majority of people I called in the classifieds. Kristin at Brookdale had. But she Walker was not the reason Brookdale is building new old age homes and creating jobs. That, again, is thanks to the supply-demand disconnect.
但是——这是一个重要的转折——我问那个LED负责人，他是否听说过沃克州长的创造就业计划。他没听过。我打电话咨询分类广告的大多数人也没听过。布鲁克代尔的克里斯汀听过。但她表示，沃克并不是布鲁克代尔建设养老院和创造就业的原因。这同样要归功于供需失衡。
Governor Scott Walker is not behind these jobs. He's not aging people or making them crave LED lighting. These jobs are created on their own. In fact, before Walker was elected, before he did anything in office, the Wisconsin Department of Revenue projected that the state would add about 190,000 jobs by 2015, Walker's deadline. So 190,000 jobs if Walker stepped into his fancy governor's office day one and proceeded to do exactly nothing all four years. If he played FarmVille on Facebook his entire term, jobs would still be created.
斯科特·沃克州长并不是这些岗位的幕后推手。他没有让人们变老，也没有让他们渴望LED照明。这些岗位是自发产生的。事实上，在沃克当选之前，在他做任何行政工作之前，威斯康星州税务局预计，到2015年（沃克的任期截止日期），该州将增加约19万个工作岗位。也就是说，即使沃克在第一天走进他豪华的州长办公室，之后四年什么都不做，也会增加19万个工作岗位。如果他整个任期都在Facebook上玩农场游戏，工作岗位依然会产生。
So another way to think about the 250,000 jobs man is that he's got 190,000 that are freebies, which means he's actually going for 60,000 to reach beyond what would happen anyway. Now, how's he going to that?
所以，“25万个岗位先生”的另一种看法是，他有19万个是“免费”的，这意味着他实际上是要争取额外的6万个岗位，超越自然增长。那么，他打算怎么做？
The Wisconsin Capitol was sieged by anti-Walker protesters for weeks in February, early March. When I arrive, it's almost April. And the Capitol looks kind of like the front lawn of a frat house Monday morning. There are a few soppy posters poking out of garbage cans, small groups of protesters show up at random hours, the drum circle has been reduced to one guy with a pail.
二月到三月初，威斯康星州议会大厦被反沃克抗议者包围了几周。我到达时，几乎已经是四月了。议会大厦看起来就像周一早上的兄弟会联谊会前院。垃圾桶里伸出几张湿透的海报，小群的抗议者在随机时间出现，鼓手圆圈已经缩减为一个人带着一个桶。
Governor Walker sits one floor above that scene. There's no whiteboard in his office with a jobs tally, no big red 250,000 target, just him in a suit with a slogan.
沃克州长坐在离那个现场一层楼的地方。他的办公室里没有写着就业统计数字的白板，没有醒目的“25万”红色目标，只有穿着西装的他和一句口号。
Wisconsin's open for business.
“威斯康星州欢迎投资。”
Scott Walker has a Clark Kent thing going on. He's sort of generically handsome. He blinks in sync with his speech. He's a fan of the word "literally." And he begins our interview by telling me about the night he won the election and introducing me to his sign, a move I'm pretty sure he uses with all the reporters. It's green. Picture a campaign poster. But this one just says,
斯科特·沃克有一种克拉克·肯特（超人）的感觉。他长相平平，眨眼节奏与说话同步。他喜欢用“字面上”这个词。采访开始时，他告诉我他获胜当晚的情景，并向我展示了他的标语，我相信他肯定对所有记者都用过这一招。标语是绿色的，就像竞选海报。但这一个只写着：
Wisconsin's open for business. In fact, I put up a sign like that literally the night I won election, November 2. From that point forward, it's about telling the state what you're going to do. And so it literally just said "Wisconsin's open for business." And we said we have a plan to help of people the state create 250,000 jobs by the end of our first term, so 250,000 jobs by 2015.
“威斯康星州欢迎投资。”实际上，我字面上在11月2日获胜的当晚就挂上了那样的标语。从那一刻起，关键就是告诉州里你要做什么。所以它字面上就是写着“威斯康星州欢迎投资”。我们说我们有一个计划，帮助州里在第一个任期结束时创造25万个就业岗位，也就是到2015年创造25万个岗位。
Walker and I talked in circles for a bit. I ask him, "But how do you do that, create jobs?" He tells me, "The private sector create jobs. The government just has to get out of the way." But, of course, his pledge was that the government led by him would create jobs. I asked for clarification, and eventually we come to this. Walker believes government helps create jobs through incentives. He speaks mostly of taxes and exclusively about lowering them, something he started working on right away.
我和沃克兜了一会儿圈子。我问他：“但你怎么做，创造就业？”他告诉我：“私营部门创造就业。政府只需要别挡路。”但是，当然，他的承诺是政府在他的领导下创造就业。我要求澄清，最终我们得出了这个结论：沃克认为政府通过激励措施帮助创造就业。他主要谈的是税收，并且专门谈到减税，这是他一上任就开始做的事情。
January 3, took the oath of office, literally called a special session. And then handed the next morning the legislature, gave them a stack of various pieces of legislation, putting things that were specifically targeted towards lowering tax burden for employers based upon jobs created.
1月3日，宣誓就职，字面上召集了一个特别会议。第二天早上交给立法机关一叠各种立法文件，把重点放在根据创造的就业岗位降低雇主的税收负担上。
Under these new laws, employers who create jobs now get a tax deduction, $2,000 to $4,000, depending on the company size, per head. So $2,000 to $4,000 deduction for each new hire. Companies that relocate to Wisconsin get two years tax free. And Walker expanded another tax credit program for companies to make capital investments that create jobs.
根据这些新法律，现在创造岗位的雇主可以获得税收抵扣，根据公司规模每人可抵扣2000至4000美元。也就是说，每雇佣一名新员工可抵扣2000至4000美元。迁往威斯康星州的公司可享受两年免税。沃克还扩大了另一个税收抵免计划，鼓励公司进行创造就业的资本投资。
Now all this, I should say, is an incredibly typical approach. Hand out goodies to entice the private sector to hire. Republicans tend to do it through tax cuts, Democrats through spending, many do both. But they're all basically after the same thing-- less money for the government, more money for the private sector, get the jobs numbers to go up.
现在所有这一切，我应该说，是一种极其典型的方法。给私营部门分发“糖果”以引诱他们雇人。共和党倾向于通过减税来做到这一点，民主党通过支出，很多人两者都做。但他们本质上都在追求同样的事情——政府少收钱，私营部门多拿钱，让就业数字上升。
How will you know that you were successful? How will you know they you created 250,000 jobs?
你如何知道你成功了？你如何知道你创造了25万个就业岗位？
We track them. We track every month. For example, the first month of this year, the Department of Workforce Development tracks the number of new jobs that are added in the private sector. In January alone, there were 10,100, approximately, new jobs created in the private sector. We'll keep building off of those patterns.
我们跟踪它们。我们每个月跟踪。例如，今年第一个月，劳动力发展部跟踪了私营部门新增岗位的数量。仅在一月份，私营部门就创造了大约10,100个新岗位。我们将继续在这些模式的基础上建立。
But how do you know that's you?
但你如何知道那是你的功劳？
Well, it's not. You don't have a personal clicker every time you talk to somebody who got a job.
好吧，那不是。你不可能每次和获得工作的人交谈时都有一个个人计数器。
This is kind of a weird thing to say. On the one hand, Walker is saying he didn't create those jobs. Government can't create jobs. But on the other hand he's saying it's helpful to have all these incentives to encourage businesses to create jobs.
这话听起来有点奇怪。一方面，沃克在说他没有创造那些工作。政府不能创造工作。但另一方面，他说拥有这些激励措施来鼓励企业创造就业是有帮助的。
I mean, for us, it's the overall climate. It's creating a job. It's selling the state. If it's an employer that I've never personally talked to, but an employer in Rice Lake, or La Crosse, or Wausau, or Green Bay says, "Things have changed. I feel better about the economy. I feel better about the state. I'm going to go out now and hire those five or ten people I was thinking about," all of those collectively, that's where the real job growth is going to come.
我的意思是，对我们来说，这是整体氛围。这是在创造一个工作岗位。这是在推销这个州。如果有一个我从未亲自交谈过的雇主，但位于莱斯湖、拉克罗斯、沃索或绿湾的一位雇主说：“情况变了。我对经济感觉更好。我对这个州感觉更好。我现在要出去雇那五六个我一直在考虑雇佣的人，”所有这些加在一起，这就是真正就业增长的来源。
Right now Walker is on target. If job growth continues at the current rate, he'll make his 250,000. And in his mind, he will have done it in a very subtle, specific way. The role Walker has cast for himself is one of professional government seducer, in which he makes the idea of hiring-- something you maybe had on the mind already-- look that much more appealing. He's adding some alcohol to a singles mixer, maybe dimming the lights a bit. And then, let the hiring begin.
目前沃克正按计划进行。如果就业增长按当前速度持续下去，他将达到25万的目标。在他心目中，他将以一种非常微妙、具体的方式做到这一点。沃克为自己扮演的角色是一位专业的政府“诱导者”，他让雇佣这个想法——你可能已经在考虑的想法——看起来更具吸引力。他给单身联谊会加了点酒精，也许灯光调暗了一点。然后，让招聘开始吧。
In a moment, I'm going to join over here and sign away. But before that, I'll take questions.
稍后，我会加入这里并签字。但在此之前，我会回答问题。
Walker signed part of his jobs legislation into law at a company called Saris in Madison. They make bike racks. It's a small business that's growing, likely job creator, good place to make an announcement like this. So a good place to test his theory, too, right? To ask if these incentives actually make a difference.
沃克在麦迪逊一家名为Saris的公司签署了他的部分就业立法。他们制造自行车架。这是一家正在成长的小企业，潜在的就业创造者，是一个进行此类宣布的好地方。所以这也是测试他理论的好地方，对吧？去询问这些激励措施是否真的能起到作用。
The CEO, Chris Fortune, was in Dallas at the Super Bowl when the governor visited. When I visited Saris, he was in the back office with a cold. And he got out a calculator.
州长访问时，首席执行官克里斯·福琼正在达拉斯参加超级碗。当我访问Saris时，他正因感冒在后台办公室。他拿出了一个计算器。
OK, let's say at the end of the year, I've hired five people. I get a $4,000 deduction for each. So $20,000 off my total income, that's a deduction, which at the end saves me something like $270 per new employee.
好的，假设到年底，我雇用了五个人。每人我可以获得4000美元的扣除。所以我的总收入减少了20000美元，这是一个扣除额，年底每雇佣一名新员工大概能为我节省270美元。
Whatever-- let's say you hire somebody at $10 an hour. That's $22,000 plus benefits. What is it, 2,080 hours a year times $10? At $2,000, I don't know. It doesn't work. The math doesn't work for me as the motivator to hire people. It may work for somebody else, these financial programs. But it doesn't work for us.
随便吧——假设你以每小时10美元的价格雇佣某人。那是22000美元加上福利。是多少，一年2080小时乘以10美元？2000美元，我不知道。这没用。作为雇佣人的动力，数学上行不通。这些金融项目可能对别人有效。但对我们来说没用。
It's strange though, because Governor Walker was here to announce these new programs to encourage businesses to hire. And yet you're saying it would do nothing for you.
这很奇怪，因为沃克州长来这里是为了宣布这些鼓励企业招聘的新项目。然而你却说这为你什么也没做。
Well, we could benefit from that if we do hire people. The thing I am saying is that what that bill does isn't going to drive our decision on what we're going to do.
好吧，如果我们确实招聘了人，我们可能会从中受益。我想说的是，这项法案所做的事情不会驱动我们将要做出的决定。
Are there employers for who the math does work who could get Walker those extra 60,000 jobs? I asked Governor Walker.
是否有雇主觉得这个数学能行得通，从而能帮沃克获得那额外的6万个岗位？我问沃克州长。
Are there companies that you can point to right now, three months into your term, and say these are companies that we've helped create jobs.
有没有你可以指出的公司，就在你任期的三个月内，可以说这些是我们帮助创造了就业的公司？
Yeah. City Brewing in La Crosse, Wisconsin has 550 people working there. They've got five lines. They want to add a sixth line. And one of the ways that we're helping them do that-- we announced just on Friday-- was we're giving them $490,000 in tax credits. Meaning if they hit those a 100 plus jobs, they get $490,000 worth of credits off of their corporate income taxes.
有的。位于威斯康星州拉克罗斯的City Brewing公司有550人在那里工作。他们有五条生产线。他们想增加第六条。我们帮助他们这样做的方法之一——就在周五宣布的——是我们给他们提供了49万美元的税收抵免。这意味着如果他们达到那100多个岗位的目标，他们就可以从企业所得税中获得价值49万美元的抵免。
I called City Brewing. They told me yes, the governor's tax incentives played a role-- at one point they even said a large role-- in their decision to hire. They'd been wanting to add that sixth line for a while. It was in the plans a year ago. They're making a $13 million investment, so $490,000 off their income taxes is a small incentive. But they said it did help push them over the edge to do it now, to say yes to job creation.
我给City Brewing打了电话。他们告诉我，是的，州长的税收激励措施发挥了作用——在某一点上他们甚至说是巨大的作用——促使他们做出招聘的决定。他们一直想增加那条第六生产线。一年前就在计划中了。他们要进行1300万美元的投资，所以49万美元的所得税抵免是一个小的激励。但他们说，这确实帮助推动他们跨过了边缘，现在就做这件事，从而说“是的，创造就业”。
So, add 100 jobs to Walker's white board. I ask him for more examples.
所以，给沃克的白板上加100个工作岗位。我请他举更多例子。
Stoughton Trailer is a good example, overall 478 jobs. They met with us. We put a package together. If they don't create the number of jobs they said, they don't get as big of an incentive.
斯托顿拖车公司是一个很好的例子，总共478个岗位。他们和我们见了面。我们制定了一个方案。如果他们没有创造他们所说的岗位数量，他们就得不到那么大的激励。
Stoughton Trailers is 20 miles southeast of Madison. You know the boxes you see trucks pulling around the highways carrying fruit, and toys, and toasters from one place to another? Stoughton makes them. Keith Wise makes the hires, 478, which is a lot of people to hire.
斯托顿拖车公司位于麦迪逊东南20英里处。你知道你在高速公路上看到卡车拉着的那些箱子，装着水果、玩具和烤面包机从一个地方运到另一个地方吗？斯托顿就是制造它们的。基思·怀斯负责招聘，478人，这是一个很大的招聘数量。
It's crazy. It's fun. It's nerve-wracking at times.
太疯狂了。很有趣。有时让人伤透脑筋。
Stoughton will get a $750,000 government loan for investing $11 million in a new plant. I ask if they would have hired the 478 people without these government programs.
斯托顿将获得75万美元的政府贷款，用于投资1100万美元建设新工厂。我问如果没有这些政府项目，他们是否会雇用这478人。
We probably would, but at a much lower rate than what we are.
我们可能会，但速度会比现在慢得多。
Slower?
更慢？
Yeah, much slower, much slower. We'll be able to a lot of people in here a lot quicker than what we normally would.
是的，慢得多，慢得多。我们将能比平时更快地让很多人进入这里。
So out of 478 jobs, maybe Walker gets to count half? Keith would not play this game with me.
所以在这478个岗位中，也许沃克能算作一半？基思不愿和我玩这个游戏。
And I can recognize that it's kind of a ridiculous game. Andrew Reschovsky, an economist at the University of Wisconsin-Madison basically told me as much. He kept repeating, look, the decision to hire someone is so complicated. Any employer he told me, has a long list of factors to consider.
而且我可以承认这是一个有点荒谬的游戏。威斯康星大学麦迪逊分校的经济学家安德鲁·雷乔夫斯基基本上就是这么对我说的。他一直在重复，看，决定雇用某人太复杂了。他告诉我，任何雇主都有很长一份需要考虑的因素清单。
Taxes are one factor, but not the most important factor. And they tend not to be at the top of the list.
税收是一个因素，但不是最重要的因素。它们通常不在清单的顶部。
It's kind of a genius political move to say that you, the politician, are going to create jobs. A job gets created and it could have been you. Or it could have been because people are getting old, because we're coming out of a recession, or because people are buying more bikes.
说你自己，政客，要去创造就业，这是一种天才的政治举动。一个工作岗位被创造了，那可能是你的功劳。或者那可能是因为人们变老了，因为我们正在走出衰退，或者因为人们正在购买更多的自行车。
How will one ever know-- if the economy grows and employment is 250,000 jobs higher four years from now than it is now, will we know that it has anything to do with government policy or not? And that's one of the very difficult, probably unanswerable questions.
一个人怎么能知道——如果经济增长，四年后就业人数比现在多了25万，我们会知道这与政府政策有任何关系吗？这是一个非常困难、可能无法回答的问题。
So we will never know if he was successful or not?
所以我们永远不会知道他是否成功了？
I think that's fair to say.
我认为这样说是公平的。
Oh, we could know that he failed, right?
噢，我们可以知道他失败了，对吧？
Yes. If, at the end of four years, only 200,000 jobs have been created, he has failed in terms of his promise.
是的。如果四年后只创造了20万个工作岗位，那么从他的承诺来看，他就是失败了。
Does that then mean that there is nothing a government can do to help create jobs?
那是否意味着政府在创造就业方面无能为力？
I wouldn't go as far as saying there is nothing a government can do. That overstates the case. Governments can make a difference. If you want to get businesses to increase hiring now, over the next year or two, you have relatively limited power.
我不会说政府什么也做不了。那样说太夸张了。政府可以有所作为。如果你想让企业在接下来的一两年内增加招聘，你的权力相对有限。
Which is, of course, exactly what you want if you're a governor. You have four years. You want the jobs now. Reschovsky says, well, if you get a governor who's willing to be patient, there are things he or she can do that will likely help create jobs. Such as--
这当然正是如果你是州长所想要的。你有四年时间。你想要现在的就业岗位。雷乔夫斯基说，好吧，如果你得到一个愿意耐心的州长，他或她可以做一些很可能会有助于创造就业的事情。比如——
I'm going to improve the quality of the state university system, or I'm going to invest in community colleges, good roads, good bridges-- so physical infrastructure-- to have an educated labor force. There are possible ways in which you can make a difference.
“我将改善州立大学系统的质量，或者我将投资于社区学院、好的道路、好的桥梁——即物质基础设施——以拥有一支受过教育的劳动力队伍。”这都是你可以有所作为的可能途径。
But you won't see those results until the end of your second term-- if you're lucky-- or until the next guy is in office.
但你看不到那些结果，直到你第二个任期结束——如果你幸运的话——或者直到下一个人上台。
So in the meantime, politicians with a jobs number to achieve focus on the short term. Republicans and Democrats hand out tax cuts and other incentives to seduce employers into hiring. And of course those goodies cost something. In Wisconsin, they account for $117 million in taxes that will not be collected over Walker's first two years. This in a state where they're fighting over every dollar.
所以在短期内，拥有就业目标任务的政客们关注的是短期。共和党和民主党发放减税和其他激励措施来引诱雇主招聘。当然，这些“糖果”是要付出代价的。在威斯康星州，它们占了沃克前两年未征收的1.17亿美元税款。在一个他们为每一美元而争斗的州里，这可是一笔钱。
So that leaves the government with less money to do the things Reschovsky is talking about, to spend on education so that employers can hire smart people, to build good roads and internet infrastructure so businesses can transport goods and innovate.
所以这就导致政府剩下的钱少了，去做雷乔夫斯基谈论的那些事情，去在教育上支出以便雇主可以雇佣聪明的人，去建设好的道路和互联网基础设施以便企业可以运输货物和创新。
If you go with tax cuts, you might seduce some employers to hire now. But you'll hurt future employers who needed you to spend on schools so they could find educated workers to come up with great new ideas. If you go with long-term spending, schools and internet, you have to increase taxes to pay for it, which can mean businesses on that job creation fence might be pushed to the anti-job-creating territory.
如果你选择减税，你可能会诱使一些雇主现在就招聘。但你会伤害未来的雇主，因为他们需要你把钱花在学校上，这样他们才能找到受过教育的工人提出伟大的新想法。如果你选择长期支出，学校和互联网，你必须增加税收来支付它，这可能意味着在创造就业方面犹豫不决的企业可能会被推向反创造就业的阵地。
In both cases, you've zeroed out your efforts. You've had some effect on the one side but canceled it out with what you did on the other side. But that's the choice you have, long-term or short-term. Whether the governor is Democrat or Republican, someone you love or someone you hate, politicians don't have a lot of options. At best they'll get a bunch of new jobs for the somersaults it took to get there. At worst, they had some impact, did something, but have no idea how to measure exactly what.
在两种情况下，你都清零了你的努力。你在某一方面产生了一些影响，但又被你在另一方面所做的事情抵消了。但这正是你有的选择，长期或短期。无论州长是民主党还是共和党，是你爱的人还是你恨的人，政客都没有太多选择。最好的情况下，他们会因为实现目标所需的翻跟头而获得一堆新的工作机会。最坏的情况下，他们产生了一些影响，做了一些事情，但根本不知道如何准确地衡量。
Chana Joffe-Walt. She's part of our Plant Money team. Planet Money is a co-production of our program and NPR News.
查娜·乔菲-沃尔特。她是我们的《金钱星球》团队的一员。《金钱星球》是我们节目和NPR新闻的联合制作。
Coming up, Oklahoma versus California, and Oklahoma wins. That is in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，俄克拉荷马州对阵加利福尼亚州，俄克拉荷马州获胜。这是芝加哥公共广播电台和公共广播国际公司在节目继续时的一分钟内容。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that team. Today's show, how to create a job.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种不同的故事。今天的节目：如何创造一个工作岗位。
Good morning. Hi.
早上好。你好。
Tuesday, Holland, Michigan.
星期二，密歇根州荷兰市。
Everybody can come this way please.
每个人都可以走这边，请。
Deborah Ozga leads five people through a sea of cubicles to be interviewed for call center jobs at Novo 1. People on headsets look up and watch them pass. Not long ago, that was them. The facility has gone from 10 employees last summer to 315 as of Tuesday. Novo 1 got a $1 million grant from the federal government and $115,000 tax abatement from the city to locate here in Holland to create those jobs.
黛博拉·奥兹加带着五个人穿过一片隔间，前往Novo 1公司面试呼叫中心的工作。戴着耳麦的人抬头看着他们经过。不久前，他们也是这样。这家工厂的员工从去年夏天的10人增加到周二的315人。Novo 1从联邦政府获得了100万美元的拨款，从城市获得了11.5万美元的减税，以落户荷兰市来创造这些就业岗位。
Tuesday they were looking to hire 15 more people, which, in the current economy, seemed like it might be a nice thing to hear. So our producer Lisa Pollack went there to record.
周二他们正在寻找招聘另外15个人，在目前的经济环境下，这听起来可能是一件令人愉快的事情。所以我们的制作人丽莎·波拉克去那里录音了。
In the conference room, Deborah explains about the company and the positions that she's filling. They're call center jobs doing roadside assistance. The pay is $9 with full benefits, $10 if you do well in your first 90 days. That's $20,800 a year.
在会议室里，黛博拉解释了公司和她正在填补的职位。它们是负责道路救援的呼叫中心工作。工资是9美元外加全额福利，如果你在前90天表现良好，就是10美元。那一年就是20800美元。
Now, I'm going to point out these things and they're going to sound negative. But I want to be realistic about the job, because I don't want to sugarcoat anything.
现在，我要指出这些事情，它们听起来很负面。但我想要对这份工作保持现实，因为我不想粉饰任何东西。
She's explains that it's a job where you log in and out every time you take a break or go to the bathroom, that computers and phones are monitored, that you pay an $80 deposit for your headset, taken from your paycheck in two installments. That it is a very structured job for people who  thrive in a structured environment.
她解释说，这份工作是每次休息或去洗手间时都要登录和注销，电脑和电话都被监控，你需要为你的耳机支付80美元的押金，分两次从你的工资中扣除。对于那些在结构化环境中茁壮成长的人来说，这是一份非常有结构的工作。
And then the interview begins. And it's a group interview, all five people at once.
然后面试开始了。这是一次集体面试，五个人同时进行。
What I'm going to do, I have a series of questions, and I'm going to go around the room. It's the same question for everybody. But try to have your own answer. When you're working in a contact center it can consist of both intense periods of activity often followed by no activity at all. I wouldn't ever say no activity. But it can go to the other extreme. How do you react in both of these situations?
我要做的是，我有一系列问题，我要在房间里转一圈。对于每个人都是同样的问题。但试着给出你自己的答案。当你在联络中心工作时，可能会有密集的活动期，通常随后是根本没有活动。我从来不会说没有活动。但它可能会走向另一个极端。在这两种情况下你如何反应？
Well, because I have a lot of years of call center experience--
嗯，因为我有多年呼叫中心的经验——
This woman was the oldest in the group, and the only one in a pantsuit, had one of those executive, leather notebook folder portfolio things with her, and seemed like a shoo-in.
这位女士是小组中年龄最大的，也是唯一穿着长裤套装的，带着那种行政人员用的皮质笔记本文件夹，看起来像是势在必得。
It's been my experience in the past to use training materials while I'm in idle time, just to brush up on some of my skills. A lot of times I like to try to review any notes I have, or maybe go back, if there's something that I haven't finished up on, to try to follow up on that.
根据我过去的经验，在空闲时间我会使用培训材料，只是为了温习一下我的一些技能。很多时候我喜欢试着复习我的笔记，或者回顾，如果有什么我还没完成的事情，我会试着跟进一下。
Once that gauntlet of an answer had been hurled-- in her downtime she simply does more work-- what's everyone else supposed to say?
一旦这个答案的“手套”被掷出——在空闲时间她只是做更多的工作——其他人还能说什么呢？
I suppose I would do something similar, go through notes for training purposes, or review my previous phone calls.
我想我会做类似的事情，为了培训目的浏览笔记，或者复习我之前的电话记录。
Just occupying the downtime in any facet that would be constructive for the company is what I would aim for. It doesn't hurt either that I'm OCD and extremely clean and tidy.
占据空闲时间，任何对公司有建设性的方面都是我的目标。我也患有强迫症，极其干净整洁，这也不坏。
Touche. Where does anybody go from there?
精彩。别人还能怎么接话？
I would always first check to see if there's anything anyone else needed help with. If somebody else was overloaded, if there was a way to transfer their next call to my station instead.
我总是会先看看别人是否需要帮助。如果有人负担过重，如果能把他们的下一个电话转接到我的工作站。
When Deborah asked the group how they feel about working in a place that's so regimented, with strict attendance policies the way Nova 1 has, again they're being interviewed. What are they going to say?
当黛博拉问小组他们如何看待在这样一个管理严格、有严格考勤制度的地方工作时，像Novo 1这样，他们再次被面试了。他们还能说什么？
Honestly, I think that's a very good thing. Because having a good attendance policy makes sure that employees are actually serious about wanting to work here, and not just there for the paycheck.
老实说，我认为这是一件非常好的事情。因为拥有良好的考勤政策确保了员工是真正严肃想要在这里工作的，而不仅仅是为了工资。
I don't like calling in, because I always feel bad for the other people. I always think of the other people before myself.
我不喜欢请假，因为我总是为其他人感到难过。我总是先想别人，再想自己。
There are three qualities that I strive for in the workplace-- punctuality, kindness, and being a team player above all else. And the fact that you guys have a strict attendance policy is a wonderful thing, because it weeds out the people who want to be there and who don't.
我在工作场所追求三种品质——守时、善良，以及最重要的团队合作精神。你们有严格的考勤政策是一件美妙的事情，因为它剔除了那些想不想在这里的人。
Deborah did two group interviews on Tuesday, 13 people in all. And a few hours after they left, Deborah sat down at her office [PHONE DIALING] for the moment of truth.
黛博拉在周二做了两次集体面试，总共13人。在他们离开几个小时后，黛博拉坐在她的办公室里，进行真相大白的时刻。
Hi John, this is Deborah calling from Nova 1. How are you? Good, good. Well, I wanted to give you a call to offer you a position here. Oh good, good. I'm so glad. You sound a little excited about this. Oh, that's so good to hear. I like when I hear that kind of answer.
嗨，约翰，我是Novo 1的黛博拉。你好吗？好的，好的。嗯，我想打电话给你提供一个职位。噢好的，好的。我真高兴。你听起来有点兴奋。噢，听到这个太好了。我喜欢听到这种回答。
I told her that it felt like a little weight has been lifted, and it definitely feels really good.
我告诉她，感觉像是一块重担被卸下了，感觉真的很好。
This, of course, is John. He's 21, worked at a Pizza Hut, sold some vacuum cleaners on commission, worked at the mall during holidays. He has never made over $8 an hour. So he was pretty excited.
这当然是约翰。他21岁，在必胜客工作过，卖过吸尘器拿佣金，节日期间在商场工作过。他从未赚过每小时8美元以上。所以他非常兴奋。
It's just really relieving, because I haven't really found a good, solid job that would pay me decently, at least give me the hours that I needed. And I went in and did my best, and she called me. It just felt so awesome. It felt really, really great.
这真的是一种解脱，因为我一直没找到一份好的、稳定的工作，能给我体面的工资，至少能给到我需要的工时。我进去面试并尽了全力，然后她给我打了电话。感觉太棒了。感觉真的，真的非常好。
The phone rang, and I answered it. And she says, "You have the position. We want to offer it to you." You almost want to scream, "Yes, I'll take it!"
电话铃响了，我接了。她说：“你得到了这个职位。我们要提供给你。”你几乎想尖叫，“是的，我会接受它！”
This is Heather, who's 30, worked at the photo studio in a Walmart for five years, but was laid off a year and half ago. Collected unemployment, which ran out in March.
这是希瑟，30岁，在沃尔玛的照片工作室工作了五年，但一年半前被裁员了。领失业救济金，在三月用完了。
Especially after I lost my unemployment, then I just pretty much  started going for anything. If I even felt like I was even remotely qualified for it, I applied for it. I applied for janitorial, I applied at a dentist office, because they said that they would train in the different dental procedures that they would actually need help with.
特别是在我失去失业救济金后，我就基本上开始寻找任何事情。只要我觉得我还有一点点资格，我就申请。我申请了清洁工作，我申请了牙医诊所，因为他们说会培训我实际上需要帮助的各种牙科程序。
I had been let down so much, I didn't want to get my hopes up. So pretty much as soon as she called me back, it was one of those things of, all right. I tried to calm myself down a little bit at first so I didn't scream at the poor woman.
我感到非常失望，我不想抱太大希望。所以基本上当她给我回电话时，就是那种“好吧”的感觉。起初我试图让自己冷静一点，这样我就不会对这个可怜的女人尖叫。
She and John start work May 23.
她和约翰在5月23日开始工作。
Which brings us to act three, Job Fairies. If you think about it, who wants to create jobs? Not businesses. Most companies would love to do whatever they do with fewer people and fewer jobs. It would be cheaper. It's us who want more jobs, and the politicians we elect. And the people who work for those politicians who are supposed to do the dirty work and make the magic happen, make the jobs appear, these are the economic development officers. And just about every town or county above a certain size, every state, has an economic development team going around trying to figure out how to get more jobs for the people who live in that place.
这把我们带到了第三幕，就业仙女。如果你想想看，谁想创造就业？不是企业。大多数公司都希望用更少的人和更少的工作岗位来做他们所做的事情。这会更便宜。是我们想要更多的工作，以及我们选出的政客。而为这些政客工作、本应做肮脏工作并创造魔法、让工作岗位出现的人，就是经济发展官员。几乎每个超过一定规模的城镇或县，每个州，都有一个经济发展团队到处试图弄清楚如何为居住在那个地方的人们获得更多工作。
Julie Snyder and Planet Money's Adam Davidson spent some time at one of their conventions in San Diego for the International Economic Development Council.
朱莉·斯奈德和《金钱星球》的亚当·戴维森在圣地亚哥为国际经济发展理事会举行的会议上花了一些时间。
When we got to the IEDC leadership conference at that Westin Hotel in San Diego a few months ago, the national unemployment rate was at 9.4%. The US lost 6 and 1/2 million jobs in the last few years.
当几个月前我们在圣地亚哥威斯汀酒店参加IEDC领导力会议时，全国失业率为9.4%。美国在过去几年里失去了650万个工作岗位。
I know. And we were thinking, god, these people are going to be so miserable. These are the people on the front lines. They're counting jobs every day. So we figured the mood here would be really bleak. We were wrong.
我知道。我们当时在想，天哪，这些人会非常痛苦。他们是前线人员。他们每天都在数就业岗位。所以我们以为这里的气氛会非常阴沉。我们错了。
The nice thing about Texas is we were not as negatively impacted as some of the rest of the states who had serious unemployment.
德克萨斯州的好处是，我们不像其他那些遭受严重失业问题的州那样受到负面影响。
Casper, Wyoming, things are going very well, as a matter of fact. We were very fortunate to not get hit in the recession as hard as many other parts of the country.
怀俄明州卡斯珀，事情进展得非常好，事实上。我们非常幸运，没有像全国许多其他地方那样受到严重打击。
Nashville is a really interesting economy. It's incredibly diverse. So we haven't been has whacked by the recession as a lot of communities.
纳什维尔是一个非常有趣的经济体。它非常多元化。所以我们没有像许多社区那样受到经济衰退的重创。
And that's very true at Augusta. We were not affected by the recession as much a lot of communities.
奥古斯塔也是如此。我们不像许多社区那样受到经济衰退的影响。
This, I swear, is only a small sample of all of the times Adam and I were assured that not only are Casper, Nashville, and Augusta doing great, but it's boom time in Houston, Oklahoma City, Jefferson Parish, Louisiana, Rio Rancho, New Mexico.
我发誓，这只是亚当和我被告知卡斯珀、纳什维尔和奥古斯塔不仅做得很好，而且休斯顿、俄克拉荷马城、路易斯安那州杰斐逊教区、新墨西哥州里奥兰乔正处于繁荣时期的次数中的一小部分。
Everybody, every single person told us about their great, great economy. The moment for me when I realized oh, they're lying, or at least oh, they're spinning, was when the economic development person from Saginaw, Michigan, was telling me how great things are going there.
每个人，每一个人都告诉我们关于他们伟大、伟大的经济。当我意识到“噢，他们在撒谎”，或者至少“噢，他们在包装”的那一刻，是密歇根州萨基诺的经济发展人员告诉我那里的一切进展得多么好时。
At that moment, Saginaw had an unemployment rate well above 13%. That is way worse than the national average. The FBI says Saginaw is the number one most violent city in America.
在那一刻，萨基诺的失业率远高于13%。这比全国平均水平糟糕得多。联邦调查局称萨基诺是美国最暴力的城市。
We heard so much boosterism at this conference. It turns out getting jobs to your city is a lot like dating. You want to act like the last thing in the world you need are jobs in your town. Your city is so cool, so in demand, so business friendly that jobs are everywhere.
我们在这次会议上听到了太多吹捧。事实证明，为你的城市获得工作岗位就像约会。你想表现得好像你世界上最不需要的东西就是你城镇里的工作岗位。你的城市是如此酷，需求如此之大，商业环境如此友好，以至于工作岗位到处都是。
There's a lot of manufacturing in Augusta. There's a huge Procter & Gamble plant there, all the Tide and Cheer detergent in the world is made in Augusta.
奥古斯塔有很多制造业。那里有一个巨大的宝洁工厂，世界上所有的汰渍和欢悦洗涤剂都是在奥古斯塔制造的。
This is this guy Walter Sprouse from Augusta, Georgia. He literally talked for a straight minute and a half listing off all of the companies in the Augusta area.
这是那个叫沃尔特·斯普劳斯的来自佐治亚州奥古斯塔的家伙。他字面上连续说了一分半钟，列举了奥古斯塔地区的所有公司。
E-Z-GO, Club Car, John Deere, all these companies are located in Augusta in addition to the ones I talking about with Proctor & Gamble. And NutraSweet is headquartered there.
E-Z-GO，Club Car，约翰迪尔，所有这些公司除了我谈到的宝洁之外都位于奥古斯塔。而且NutraSweet总部也在那里。
Yeah, he's showing that he's business friendly. That's the key for economic development. If you have a lot of unemployment--
是的，他是在展示他是商业友好的。这是经济发展的关键。如果你有很高的失业率——
Wait, Adam.
等等，亚当。
Yeah?
嗯？
He's not done.
他还没说完。
Solo Cup, all these companies. Automatic Data Processing employs about 1,000 people.
Solo Cup，所有这些公司。自动数据处理公司雇佣了大约1000人。
OK, OK, I get it. But, of course, you don't want any business who might be thinking of coming to your town to hear that you have high unemployment, the people there are near depression levels. Because that might signal that you're some lame loserville with high taxes, tons of regulation, or a low skill base, meaning people in your town are uneducated or stupid.
好的，好的，我明白了。但是，当然，你不想让任何可能考虑来到你的城镇的企业听到你有高失业率，那里的人们接近抑郁水平。因为那可能表明你是一个税收高、监管多、技能基础低的可怜虫，意味着你镇上的人都没受过教育或很蠢。
So how do these people create jobs in their communities? First they do something that they like to call business attraction.
那么这些人如何在他们的社区创造就业？首先他们做他们喜欢称之为“商业吸引”的事情。
Yeah, that's what they call it, business attraction. I came up with a different word. I call it stealing. They're trying to steal jobs from each other. After a few hours, I was thinking this conference is like a convention of incredibly collegial pickpockets. Everyone's politely sharing tricks of the trade, telling war stories, and all the time they're sizing each other up, figuring out, hey, what has that guy got that I could steal?
是的，他们称之为“商业吸引”。我用了另一个词。我称之为“窃取”。他们试图互相窃取工作岗位。几个小时后，我在想这个会议就像一个极其团结的扒手大会。每个人都在礼貌地分享交易技巧，讲述战争故事，同时他们互相评估，心想，嘿，那个家伙有什么我可以偷的？
The economic developers definitely did not like to talk about stealing. When it would come up, they would smile awkwardly and try and change the conversation. Let's go back around to listing all the advantages of their city. That's basically what Janet Miller did, the head of Nashville's Chamber of Commerce, when I asked her about stealing. But she did admit it's her job to pay attention to what's going on in other places.
经济发展人员绝对不喜欢谈论“窃取”。当它被提及时，他们会尴尬地微笑并试图改变话题。让我们回到列举他们城市的所有优势上来。这就是纳什维尔商会负责人珍妮特·米勒在我问她关于窃取时所做的事情。但她确实承认，注意其他地方正在发生的事情是她的工作。
But we watch things. I mean, Illinois raised their income tax. The legislature voted last week on that. And there was a lot of chatter in the economic development online community about opportunity. And you hate to feel like you're preying off of other people's misfortune. But the reality of it is there are going to be corporations that are going to seek more pro-business environments. And so you want to be ahead of the curve if that's the case.
但我们关注事物。我的意思是，伊利诺伊州提高了所得税。立法机关上周投票通过了。在线经济发展社区里有很多关于“机会”的闲聊。你讨厌感觉自己在掠夺他人的不幸。但现实是，会有企业寻求更亲商业的环境。所以如果是这样的话，你想领先于曲线。
Nashville took some hits during the recession, primarily in manufacturing. But it's a powerhouse for health care companies and, of course, music and entertainment. Now Janet is focusing her business attraction skills on those two industries. She doesn't always expect whole companies will move, but maybe she can get one department or a growing division to relocate.
纳什维尔在经济衰退期间遭受了一些打击，主要是制造业。但它是医疗保健公司，当然还有音乐和娱乐业的强国。现在珍妮特正将她的商业吸引技能专注于这两个行业。她并不总是期望整个公司会搬迁，但也许她可以获得一个部门或一个正在增长的分支机构来重新安置。
Honestly, once I leave here, I'm going to meet our mayor in LA, and we're going to see entertainment companies that are LA-based that either have Nashville operations or that we'd like to have Nashville operations. Then we're going on to San Francisco and focusing entirely on health care.
老实说，一旦我离开这里，我就去见我们在洛杉矶的市长，我们将去看看那些总部位于洛杉矶但有纳什维尔业务，或者我们希望有纳什维尔业务的娱乐公司。然后我们将去旧金山，完全专注于医疗保健。
You really got the sense that the number one activity for economic development people all over the country is to figure out, how do I steal companies away from California? California is, of course, the most populated state, the biggest economy in the US. And it's got some of the strictest regulations in the country, some of the highest taxes.
你真的感觉到全国各地的经济发展人员的首要活动是弄清楚，我如何从加利福尼亚窃取公司？加利福尼亚当然是人口最多的州，美国最大的经济体。而且它有一些全国最严格的监管，一些最高的税收。
I met this one woman, Ioanna Morfessis, from Phoenix. She used to run the Greater Phoenix Economic Development team. And she was the one person who loved talking about how much fun it was to steal jobs from California.
我遇到了一个叫乔安娜·莫菲西斯的女人，来自凤凰城。她曾负责大凤凰城经济发展团队。她是唯一喜欢谈论从加利福尼亚窃取工作有多有趣的人。
All is fair in love, war, resumes, and economic development.
在爱情、战争、简历和经济发展方面，一切都是公平的。
Because you guys, a big part of your job is to convince companies to come.
因为你们，你们工作的一大部分是说服公司来。
Well, that's correct.
嗯，那是正确的。
To steal companies.
去窃取公司。
Well, to the extent a company is going to leave, why not come to greater Phoenix? We opened a full-time office in California and really worked the market hard.
嗯，在一家公司要离开的程度上，为什么不来大凤凰城呢？我们在加利福尼亚设立了一个全职办公室，真的努力开拓了市场。
You opened an office just to convince companies to leave California?
你们为了说服公司离开加利福尼亚专门开了一个办公室？
We had three people over there including myself, quite extensively.
我们有三个人在那里，包括我自己，非常广泛地工作。
Wow. How many companies did you get to come?
哇。你们带来了多少公司？
We probably opened it around 1990, early 1991. And we brought about 85 companies that represented employment probably around maybe a total of 20,000 jobs.
我们大概在1990年、1991年初开设了它。我们带来了大约85家公司，代表的就业岗位总共大概是20000个。
Wow, California must hate you.
哇，加利福尼亚一定恨你们。
Well, hey, that was then. This is now. Now they're skipping over Arizona, New Mexico, and they're going to Oklahoma.
嘿，那是过去。这是现在。现在他们跳过了亚利桑那州、新墨西哥州，他们正在去俄克拉荷马州。
Oklahoma, the hero at this conference. The most business-friendly state according to lots of the people who spoke here. Most of the country has been suffering, and Oklahoma's economy is on fire. Oklahoma City has been a leader in job growth. Over the last five years, it was ranked America's most recession-proof city by Forbes magazine.
俄克拉荷马州，这次会议上的英雄。根据这里发言的许多人，它是最商业友好的州。全国大部分地区一直在受苦，而俄克拉荷马州的经济正在燃烧。俄克拉荷马城一直是就业增长的领导者。在过去五年里，它被《福布斯》杂志评为美国最抗衰退的城市。
Oklahoma city is known for what's called a low-cost, high-value combination. And they're snagging jobs from across the country, making headlines last year when Boeing announced a plan to move 550 engineers there from Seattle.
俄克拉荷马城以所谓的低成本、高价值组合而闻名。他们正在从全国各地抢走工作岗位，去年当波音宣布一项计划将550名工程师从西雅图迁往那里时，登上了头条。
This is what drove me crazy about this conference, actually about the whole profession of economic development. They're not creating jobs. They're just moving jobs around. Arizona steals a company from California by offering some tax break and lighter regulation. Then Texas cuts taxes a bit more, does away with even more regulation, and gets the company to move there. That doesn't help anything. We still have the same number of jobs. But now we have this race to the bottom. Who can cut back government services the most? Who can eliminate the most regulation?
这正是让我对这次会议感到疯狂的事情，实际上是对整个经济发展职业。他们没有创造工作。他们只是在四处搬运工作。亚利桑那州通过提供一些税收减免和更轻的监管从加利福尼亚偷走了一家公司。然后德克萨斯州进一步削减税收，取消更多监管，并让公司迁往那里。那没有任何帮助。我们依然有同样多的工作。但现在我们有了这场“竞相逐底”。谁能削减最多的政府服务？谁能消除最多的监管？
Something else we learned here, economic development is actually really trendy work. Everyone gets obsessed by the same way of attracting businesses. It used to be smokestack chasing, trying to get that one big factory to come to your town. But then that one big factory ended up in China and places like that.
我们在那里学到的另一件事，经济发展其实是一种非常时髦的工作。每个人都沉迷于吸引企业的相同方式。过去是“追逐烟囱”，试图让那一家大工厂来到你的城镇。但那一家大工厂最终去了中国那样的地方。
Then the big trend was clusters, getting lots of the same kinds of companies in the same industry all in one place, you know, like Silicon Valley. Suddenly every small town with a junior college was announcing we're going to become a major biotech cluster.
然后大趋势是“集群”，把同一个行业里的许多相同类型的公司都放在同一个地方，你知道，就像硅谷。突然间，每个有初级学院的小镇都宣布我们要成为一个主要的生物技术集群。
Which then leads to the next big trend. Creative cities, modeled after places like Austin, Texas, create a quote unquote "cool place for people to live." The young and smart will flock there. They'll open a coffee shop. They'll open a tattoo parlor. And hopefully those crazy kids will start to build a tech empire.
这就导致了下一个大趋势。模仿奥斯汀、德克萨斯州等地方建立“创意城市”，创造一个所谓的“让人们居住的酷地方”。年轻而聪明的人会蜂拥而至。他们会开一家咖啡店。他们会开一家纹身店。希望那些疯狂的孩子会开始建立一个技术帝国。
You know, I've always said it, Julie. Tattoo parlors means massive economic growth.
你知道，我一直这么说，朱莉。纹身店意味着巨大的经济增长。
The next wave, the one just getting popular now, has kind of a dorky name. Economic gardening. But the idea is forget about bringing the big, established companies to your town. Help the people who already live there become entrepreneurs, start their own businesses. This involves a lot of small, painstaking work, gathering market research for local businesses, helping them look for expansion opportunities, set them up with small business loans, things like that.
下一波，现在才刚刚流行起来的，有一个有点呆的名字。经济园艺。但想法是忘记把大型、成熟的公司带到你的城镇。帮助已经住在那里的人成为企业家，创办他们自己的企业。这涉及许多小的、艰苦的工作，为当地企业收集市场研究，帮助他们寻找扩张机会，为他们安排小企业贷款，诸如此类的事情。
I talked to Robert Barnes, an economic developer from Casper, Wyoming, and told him I thought it seemed like a lot of work for maybe a small return. But he disagreed.
我与来自怀俄明州卡斯珀的经济发展员罗伯特·巴恩斯谈过，告诉他我觉得这看起来像是为了可能很小的回报而做了很多工作。但他不同意。
Because companies that grow in a community tend to stay in the community.
因为在社区中成长的公司倾向于留在社区里。
Is that frustrating, though? Because really you could do a ton of work-- help them secure loans, help them with expertise on getting going-- but five years from now they still could only be 15 people.
那令人沮丧吗？因为实际上你可以做大量的工作——帮他们获得贷款，帮他们提供专业知识——但五年后他们可能依然只有15个人。
Thank you, we'll take 15 jobs in a new company, absolutely.
谢谢，我们会接受一家新公司里的15个岗位，绝对。
Really, you don't mind?
真的，你不介意？
Absolutely. Why would we mind? Why would we mind having a new company?
绝对。我们为什么会介意？我们为什么会介意拥有一家新公司？
It doesn't look that impressive.
它看起来并不那么令人印象深刻。
Well, a few things we want to talk about. Those days of large announcements-- 2,000 jobs, 1,000 jobs-- the life cycle has changed. At one point in our economy that was true. Now they're very, very rare. We will take 15 jobs.
嗯，有几件事我们想谈谈。那些大规模宣布的日子——2000个岗位，1000个岗位——生命周期已经改变了。在我们经济的某个时刻那是真的。现在它们非常、非常罕见。我们会接受15个岗位。
When I learned about this, the economic gardening entrepreneurship approach, I loved it. Because if it works, it actually is increasing the number of jobs in the world. It's making the country richer.
当我了解这一点，经济园艺企业家精神方法时，我爱上了它。因为如果它奏效，它实际上是在增加世界上工作岗位的数量。它正在使国家更富有。
But how many jobs is it increasing?
但它增加了多少工作岗位？
Yeah, we couldn't get an answer to that question, could we? This turned out to be a major issue for economic development people. Because they just don't know how to count those jobs. In fact, they're so obsessed with it, there were two separate sessions at this conference devoted to figuring out how to solve this problem.
是的，我们无法得到那个问题的答案，不是吗？这对经济发展人员来说是一个主要问题。因为他们只是不知道如何数那些岗位。事实上，他们对此太沉迷了，会议上有两个独立的会议致力于解决这个问题。
I can tell you that for every dollar in investment that I've made, I returned $72 to the local economy.
我可以告诉你，我每投入一美元，我就为当地经济回报了72美元。
This is Tim Chase, head of the Chamber of Commerce in Wichita Falls, Texas. And he runs this committee of economic developers. They're trying to solve this problem. It's not just how do we count the jobs we create through economic gardening. Perhaps more importantly, it's how do we convince our bosses we're creating jobs through economic gardening?
这是蒂姆·蔡斯，德克萨斯州威奇托福尔斯商会负责人。他运营着这个经济发展委员会。他们正在试图解决这个问题。不仅是如何数我们通过经济园艺创造的岗位。也许更重要的是，我们如何说服老板我们通过经济园艺正在创造就业？
Be very careful that your leadership and their expectation for the reward ratio is in line with the realities of entrepreneurship versus expansion and recruitment.
一定要非常小心，你的领导层及其对回报率的预期与企业家精神相对于扩张和招聘的现实相一致。
But actually I don't understand what that means. A reward ratio?
但实际上我不明白那意味着什么。回报率？
I think, if I understand what he's saying correctly, is basically in this new world, where there aren't many big factories moving around, you've got to spend a lot more money and a lot more time to get a lot fewer jobs. That's a lower reward ratio.
我想，如果我正确理解了他的话，基本上是在这个新世界里，没有多少大工厂四处搬迁，你必须投入更多的钱和更多的时间来获得更少的工作岗位。那是一个较低的回报率。
And their expectation for the reward ratio is in line with the reality--
而他们对回报率的预期与现实相一致——
And you'd better hope that your bosses, your leadership, are OK with those realities, or the job you'll have to worry about the most will be your own.
你最好希望你的老板、你的领导层对那些现实感到满意，否则你最需要担心的工作将是你自己的。
I found this particular section the most revealing of the whole conference. Because most of these economic developers come from places that have been losing jobs for years. And they really have one assignment, increase the number of jobs in your town. And when you don't have a lot of success to show for it-- they're great at sales, they're great spinners-- but they really need to be able to prove to their bosses, hey, I'm worthwhile. I'm doing something valuable to our community even if you can't see it, even if we have fewer jobs this year than we did last year.
我发现这一节是整个会议中最揭示性的。因为这些经济发展人员大多数来自多年来一直失去工作岗位的地方。他们确实只有一个任务，增加你镇上工作岗位的数量。当你没有多少成就可以展示时——他们擅长销售，他们擅长包装——但他们确实需要能够向老板证明，嘿，我是值得的。即使你看不到，即使我们今年的工作岗位比去年少，我也在为我们的社区做一些有价值的事情。
You and I had a different take on the conference, though. I left there thinking, good. These people are good. I think it's good to support businesses. It's good to help them grow. It's good to be thinking about how to bring more jobs into the city in the future. Even more important now during a slowdown to be planning this stuff.
不过你和我对这次会议有不同的看法。我离开那里时心想，好。这些人很好。我认为支持企业是好的。帮助它们成长是好的。思考未来如何给城市带来更多工作岗位是好的。在放缓期间规划这些东西现在更重要。
I don't know, I didn't think they were evil or anything. But I just felt like they're not making a big difference. We tried to figure this out. We tried to measure the impact that all these economic development people have on the national economy. What we found is that there's no data. There's no way to measure. Do they make America richer? Do they make America poorer? Do they have no effect at all?
我不知道，我不认为他们是邪恶之类的。但我只是觉得他们没有做出很大的改变。我们试图弄清楚这一点。我们试图衡量所有这些经济发展人员对国民经济的影响。我们发现没有数据。没有办法衡量。他们使美国更富有了吗？他们使美国更贫穷了吗？他们根本没有影响吗？
OK, but we could find local numbers, local economic developers have those numbers. So let's use, for an example, Houston.
好的，但我们可以找到本地数据，本地经济发展人员有那些数据。所以让我们用休斯顿作为一个例子。
Yeah, they're considered one of the best economic development teams in the country and one of the best economic development states.
是的，他们被认为是国内最好的经济发展团队之一和最好的经济发展州之一。
Yeah, so the guy who runs economic development there, he told me that they're doing great. And because of an economic development plan that they've had in place, they're increasing the number of jobs in the Houston area by 140,000 jobs over a 10-year period. They're halfway there into their plan now, and they're right on track.
是的，所以运营那里经济发展的人，他告诉我他们做得很好。而且由于他们实施的一项经济发展计划，他们在10年期间内将休斯顿地区的就业岗位增加了14万个。他们现在已经完成计划的一半了，而且正如计划进行。
All right so that they've created around 70,000 jobs over five years. And that's great news for those 70,000. Let's do some math, though. That's around 14,000 jobs a year. Now I looked it up. The Houston area has around 2.7 million jobs. So if their numbers are right, the economic development people added 1/2 of 1% of the jobs in Houston each year.
好的，所以他们在五年内创造了大约7万个岗位。这对那7万人来说是好消息。不过让我们做点数学。那大约是每年14000个工作岗位。现在我查了一下。休斯顿地区大约有270万个岗位。所以如果他们的数字是正确的，经济发展人员每年增加了休斯顿岗位总数的0.5%。
Oh, that does seem kind of low.
噢，那看起来确实有点低。
I also saw that Houston has 240,000 people who are out of work who are looking for work. So it just shows you that economic development, even when it's at it's best, even when it's really, really successful, it's just not going to solve the fundamental problems of our economy. And maybe that's just asking too much anyway. I mean, most of these economic developers said that they're basically like the rest of us. They're waiting. They're waiting and hoping that this economy will turn around, that companies will start doing better, and they'll start hiring again.
我还看到休斯顿有24万失业且正在找工作的人。所以这只是表明经济发展，即使在它最好的时候，即使在它非常、非常成功的时候，也只是无法解决我们经济的基本问题。而且也许这本来就是要求太多。我的意思是，这些经济发展人员大多数说他们基本上和我们其他人一样。他们在等待。他们等待并希望这个经济会好转，企业会开始做得更好，他们会开始再次招聘。
Adam Davidson and Julie Snyder.
亚当·戴维森和朱莉·斯奈德。
[MUSIC - "OKLAHOMA" BY THE ANSWERING MACHINE]
[音乐 - "Oklahoma" by The Answering Machine]
Act Four, Be Cool, Stay in School.
第四幕，冷静，留在学校。
OK, here's something I didn't know before we started working on this week's radio show. I knew that 9% of Americans are unemployed. But college graduates, their unemployment rate is half that, 4.5%. People with PhDs, it's even better, 2% unemployment. High school grads are right near the national average, 9.7% unemployment. And people who did not graduate high school, their unemployment rate is almost 15%, which means the unemployment problem in this country is mostly a problem for the uneducated, the unskilled.
好的，这是一些我在我们开始做这周的广播节目之前不知道的事情。我知道9%的美国人失业。但大学毕业生，他们的失业率是那的一半，4.5%。拥有博士学位的人，甚至更好，2%的失业率。高中毕业生正好在全国平均水平附近，9.7%的失业率。而那些没有高中毕业的人，他们的失业率几乎是15%，这意味着这个国家的失业问题主要是受教育程度低、技能低的人的问题。
And what's strange is that those economic development people that Adam and Julie just talked to, they are mostly focused on attracting jobs for the highly educated, for people with at least college degrees. In putting together this week's show, we spent a lot of time looking for some economic development person, some politician, who's trying to attract or help businesses that specifically employ the population that needs the jobs the most, the undereducated. We reached out to industry groups. We called people around the country. We couldn't find anybody specifically trying to attract jobs for this group.
奇怪的是，亚当和朱莉刚刚谈到的那些经济发展人员，他们大多专注于为受教育程度高的人、至少有大学学位的人吸引工作。在整理这周的节目时，我们花了很多时间寻找某个经济发展人员，某个政客，他正在试图吸引或帮助专门雇佣最需要工作的群体——受教育程度低的人——的企业。我们联系了行业组织。我们给全国各地的人打电话。我们找不到任何人专门试图为这个群体吸引工作。
But what does exist for this population are programs that try to transform those high school dropouts into people with the skills that employers are looking for. Adam Davidson visited one of these programs in Rochester, New York, to see it in action.
但确实存在针对该人群的项目，试图将那些高中辍学生转变为拥有雇主正在寻找的技能的人。亚当·戴维森在纽约州罗切斯特访问了其中一个项目，去观察它的实际行动。
Pathstone is a large nonprofit that tries to get jobs for the people who have the hardest time getting employed, former drug dealers, high school dropouts, people with prison records.
Pathstone是一个大型非营利组织，试图为最难就业的人群找工作，前毒贩、高中辍学生、有犯罪记录的人。
So is everybody at step nine? OK. You guys also have a blank piece of paper, right? So what I need you guys to do is you're going to fold this into 16 pieces.
所以每个人都在第九步吗？好的。你们每个人也有一张空白的纸，对吧？所以我需要你们做的是把这个折成16个小块。
Danielle Johnson is teaching a class that's part of the Pathways Out of Poverty program. This session has about 15 people, most of them women, mostly in their 20s. There are a few guys with prison records, a few older people. The first class focuses on the most basic of life skills, like identifying what it is you want out of life.
丹妮尔·约翰逊正在教授“走出贫困途径”项目的一部分课程。这次会议大约有15个人，大部分是女性，多在20多岁。有几个有犯罪记录的男人，几个年龄大的人。第一节课专注于最基本的生活技能，比如确定你想要什么。
OK, so what you want to is open the piece of paper, and for about that next, I'll say three to five minutes, I want you to write in the boxes things that you want. You know, do you want a vacation? Everybody should be, I want to me working, employment, anything that you want.
好的，所以你想要的是打开纸，在大约接下来的，我会说三到五分钟，我想要你写在框里你想要的东西。你知道，你想要一个假期吗？每个人都应该写，我想要工作、就业，任何你想要的东西。
The main thing going on here is just a weeding people out, the people who can't show up on time, or can't act appropriately, or who wear the kind of clothes that employers would not want. A big issue, they tell me, is basic hygiene. They need to teach some students about deodorant. The idea is, if you can't behave correctly in this class, we're not going to recommend you for a job.
这里进行的主要事情只是一个筛选过程，剔除那些不能准时出现、或者不能表现得体、或者穿雇主不会喜欢的衣服的人。他们告诉我，一个大问题是基本卫生。他们需要教一些学生关于除臭剂的知识。想法是，如果你不能在这门课上表现得当，我们不会推荐你去工作。
The other big challenge? Getting the people in class to think long-term, to understand that sacrifices today can mean good things in the future.
另一个大挑战？让班上的人进行长远思考，理解今天的牺牲可能意味着未来会有好事发生。
The things that I want in my life. One, I would like to be working. I would like to go see my boyfriend up north.
我在生活中想要的东西。第一，我想要工作。我想要去北方看我的男朋友。
Is he in prison?
他在监狱里吗？
Yeah. I want to get my GED. I want to own my own business. I want to go on a vacation with my family. I want a car. I want a baby one day. I want to fly on an airplane and face my fears. I want some candy. I want to spend the night with Plies.
是的。我想要拿到我的GED。我想要拥有自己的生意。我想要和我的家人去度假。我想要一辆车。我想要有一天有一个宝宝。我想要坐飞机面对我的恐惧。我想要一些糖果。我想要和Plies一起过夜。
Who is Plies?
Plies是谁？
He's a rapper. It's my favorite artist.
他是一个说唱歌手。是我最喜欢的艺术家。
The students who make it on time most days, who show the teacher they can behave, dress, wash, they get to graduate to phase two. Of the 170 students who started the two-week class, 88 graduated to phase two.
大多数日子能准时到达，向老师展示他们能表现、穿着、清洗的学生，他们可以毕业进入第二阶段。在开始两周课程的170名学生中，88人毕业进入第二阶段。
In phase two you get some training in things like energy efficient construction techniques. Of the 88 people who started, 45 finished that second course, and now get paid around $12 an hour to do things like weatherize homes, you know, spray insulation in old houses to make them more energy efficient. All of this-- the classes, the weatherizing jobs-- are paid for by a multimillion dollar stimulus package grant from the US Department of Labor to simultaneously promote employment and green technology.
在第二阶段，你会得到一些关于节能建筑技术之类的培训。在开始的88人中，45人完成了那门课程，现在获得每小时约12美元的报酬去做诸如房屋防风防雨之类的活，你知道，在旧房子里喷涂绝缘材料使它们更节能。所有这些——课程、防风防雨工作——都是由美国劳工部的一份数百万美元的刺激方案拨款支付的，以同时促进就业和绿色技术。
That means that when the grant runs out in early 2012, those jobs will go away. By that point, the government will have spent $2 million to create 90 jobs. That's around $22,000 a job.
这意味着当拨款在2012年初用完时，那些工作岗位将消失。到那时，政府将花费200万美元创造90个工作岗位。大约每人22000美元。
Rochester actually has some really good jobs. The big companies in town-- Kodak, Xerox, Bausch and Lomb-- created this cluster of companies that deal with lenses, camera lenses, copier lens, contact lenses. And lenses are really hot business right now. Every phone's got one, every computer, DVD player, scanner.
罗切斯特实际上确实有一些很好的工作岗位。城里的大公司——柯达、施乐、博士伦——创造了这个处理镜头的公司集群，摄像镜头、复印机镜头、隐形眼镜。而且镜头现在是真正热门的生意。每个手机都有一个，每个电脑、DVD播放机、扫描仪。
Around 1/3 of the people at these companies have advanced degrees like PhDs in optical engineering to do research into new lens technology. But 1/3 to 1/2 of the jobs in these companies are for people who don't even have BAs-- high school grads, even some people with GEDs. And those jobs pay pretty well. Even with just a high school degree, you could easily make $50,000 a year. And in Rochester, that's solidly middle class.
这些公司里大约1/3的人拥有光学工程博士等高级学位，致力于研究新技术。但这些公司里1/3到1/2的工作岗位是给那些甚至没有学士学位的人——高中毕业生，甚至一些有GED的人。而且这些工作报酬相当不错。即使只有高中学位，你也很容易赚到一年5万美元。而在罗切斯特，那是扎实的中产阶级。
And that's what Pathstone wants for their clients. Their most ambitious goal is to get the graduates from the weatherizing program to eventually get those good paying jobs in the lens business. They worked with Monroe Community College to develop some training programs. I talked to Tom Finch from Monroe. And he says they are fully focused on getting this population jobs in those high-tech areas.
而那正是Pathstone为他们的客户所想要的。他们最雄心勃勃的目标是让防风防雨项目的毕业生最终获得镜头业务中那些高薪工作。他们与门罗社区学院合作开发了一些培训项目。我与门罗的汤姆·芬奇谈过。他说他们完全专注于让这个群体在那些高科技领域获得工作。
Lasers, photonics, optics.
激光、光子学、光学。
Is it realistic to think that some of the folks, some of the Pathstone clients, is that a reasonable goal for them to work in those fields?
认为一些人，一些Pathstone客户可以从事这些领域，是一个合理的目标吗？
Absolutely. It's already happened. Over the last two years, we've been very successful in creating an optics apprenticeship program. And primarily, the students that participated in that program were either laid off, or out of high school in search of a GED.
绝对。它已经发生了。在过去两年里，我们成功创建了一个光学学徒项目。参与该项目的学生主要是被裁员的，或者是离开高中寻找GED的。
How many people are in that?
里面有多少人？
The original program I believe graduated nine. But as a first time, a pilot program, nine is a very strong number. I think we started with 12, finished 9.
最初的项目我相信有9人毕业。但作为第一次，一个试点项目，9是一个非常强的数字。我想我们从12人开始，完成了9人。
I have to say, it's nine more than I imagined was possible.
我不得不说，这比我能想象的多了9个人。
Sure.
当然。
But how many people are in need? Tens of thousands? Hundreds of thousands? Could you get it to tens of thousands?
但有多少人需要？成千上万？几十万？你能让它达到成千上万吗？
Tens of thousands in optics, and lasers, and in photonics, I think it would be a stretch.
在光学、激光和光子学领域有成千上万，我认为那将是一个挑战。
Most of the students at Pathstone, their parents or grandparents came to Rochester in the 1960s and '70s. That was when Rochester was one of those incredible places where everyone who wanted a job could have a job. Kodak, Xerox, Bausch and Lomb, they just needed bodies to work their factories.
Pathstone的大多数学生，他们的父母或祖父母在20世纪60年代和70年代来到罗切斯特。那时罗切斯特是一个不可思议的地方，每个想要工作的人都可以有一份工作。柯达、施乐、博士伦，他们只是需要身体来运作他们的工厂。
One guy at Pathstone told me how his mom and uncles moved to Rochester from West Virginia to get away from the coal mines. They didn't have a lot of education. But they came to town, and right away everyone got good jobs at Kodak. They were able to buy their own houses, take vacations, live a real middle class life. That just doesn't exist anymore. But not for the reasons you think.
Pathstone的一个家伙告诉我他的妈妈和叔叔们是如何为了远离煤矿从西弗吉尼亚搬到罗切斯特的。他们没有多少教育。但他们来到城里，每个人很快就在柯达得到了好工作。他们能够买自己的房子，去度假，过真正的中产阶级生活。那现在不存在了。但不是因为你想的原因。
It's not true, even though you hear it all the time, that the US doesn't make stuff anymore. We're still the world's number one manufacturer, although China will probably edge us out sometime this year. We still have lots of factories turning out lots and lots of stuff. But pretty much everyone in those factories needs to have some basic math proficiency. They need to be trusted with expensive, precision equipment.
即使你经常听到它，美国不再制造东西也不是真的。我们依然是世界第一大制造业国家，尽管中国可能会在今年某个时候超过我们。我们依然有很多工厂生产大量的东西。但那些工厂里的每个人基本上都需要具备一些基本的数学能力。他们需要被信任去使用昂贵的、精密设备。
You're probably not getting a factory job if you don't have at least a high school degree and some advanced technical training. The experts call it high school plus. If you don't have a high school degree plus some more training, some more specialized skill, you are increasingly locked out of the middle class. And that's a lot of people, 80 million Americans over 25. That's 40% of the adult population are in that group.
如果你至少没有高中学位和一些高级技术培训，你可能无法得到一份工厂工作。专家称之为“高中以上”。如果你没有高中学位加上更多的培训，更多的专业技能，你将越来越多地被排除在中产阶级之外。而那是很多人，8000万25岁以上的美国人。那是成年人口的40%在那个群体中。
Having some training or education after high school used to be a great way, one of the most reliable ways, to make it into the middle class. But over the next few years, more and more, it'll be the only way.
拥有一些高中以后的培训或教育曾经是进入中产阶级的绝佳途径，最可靠的途径之一。但在接下来的几年里，越来越多，它将成为唯一的途径。
Adam Davidson from the Planet Money team. Their free podcast and blog is at www.npr.org/money. Planet Money also has the cover story in the June issue of Wired magazine.
来自《金钱星球》团队的亚当·戴维森。他们的免费播客和博客在www.npr.org/money。《金钱星球》也在《连线》杂志6月刊上有封面报道。
Well, our program was produced today by our senior producer, Julie Snyder, and Adam Davidson, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, and Alissa Shipp. Production help from Eric Mennel. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon's our office manager. Jen Berman's filling in as our West Coast producer.
嗯，我们的节目今天由高级制作人朱莉·斯奈德和亚当·戴维森制作，还有亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、简·费尔特斯、莎拉·柯尼格、乔纳森·门吉瓦、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩和阿丽莎·希普。埃里克·门内尔提供了制作帮助。赛斯·林德是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理。詹·伯曼是我们的西海岸制作人。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, which has all kinds of new features as of this week, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss Torey Malatia, who was upset when I showed up at work yesterday late, mean, and just wanting to be left alone.
我们的网站，本周有各种新功能，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司分发。WBEZ的管理层对我们节目的监督由我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚负责，当我昨天晚到工作、刻薄且只想被独自留下时，他很生气。
There are three qualities that I strive for in a workplace-- punctuality, kindness, and being a team player above all else.
我在工作场所追求三种品质——守时、善良，以及最重要的团队合作精神。
Oh well. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
噢好吧。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际公司。